Intro. Hey there, fellow farmers and
agriculture
enthusiasts. Ever wondered how those
neat hay bales end up in the field?
Well, you're in for a treat today
because we're diving into the world of
hay bailing. I'm your name and in this
video, we'll cover everything you need
to know about hay bailing. From the
equipment to the techniques and even
proper storage, we've got you covered.
So, grab your work gloves and let's get
started with hay bailing 101.
main content. Let's kick things off by
talking about the types of hay balor.
There are two main types, round balorers
and square bailers. Round bailers create
those big cylindrical bales you often
see in fields. They're great for large
scale operations and outdoor storage.
Square balers, on the other hand,
produce rectangular bales. These are
easier to stack and transport, making
them ideal for smaller farms. Each type
has its pros and cons, so choose based
on your specific needs. Now, let's walk
through the bailing process step by
step. First, you need to cut the hay and
let it dry in the field. This usually
takes a few days, depending on the
weather. Once the hay is dry, it's time
to rake it into
windrows. Windows are long lines of hay
that make it easier for the bor to pick
up. Next, you'll drive your tractor with
the bor attached over the windross. The
bor picks up the hay and compresses it
into bales. For round balor, the hay is
rolled into a cylinder. Square bailers
compress the hay into rectangular
shapes. Once the bail reaches the right
size, it's tied with twine or net wrap.
The bor then releases the finished bail
onto the field. After bailing, proper
storage is crucial to maintain hay
quality. If you're storing round bales
outside, place them on a well- drained
area. Arrange them in rows with the flat
ends
touching. This helps shed water and
prevents moisture from seeping in. For
square bales, it's best to store them
indoors if possible. Stack them on
pallets to keep them off the ground.
Ensure good ventilation to prevent mold
growth. If you must store square bales
outside, cover them with a tarp. Make
sure the tarp doesn't touch the ground
to allow air
circulation. Now, let's talk about some
common bailing issues you might
encounter. One frequent problem is
uneven bales. This can happen if you're
driving too fast or if the wind rows are
uneven. Another issue is bales that are
too loose or too tight. Adjust your bor
settings to fix this problem.
Sometimes you might experience twine or
net wrap failures. Check your bor's
tying mechanism and make sure you're
using quality
materials. Moisture in the hay can lead
to mold or even spontaneous
combustion. Always ensure your hay is
properly dried before bailing. To keep
your bor in top shape, regular
maintenance is key. Clean your bor after
each use to remove hay and debris.
Lubricate all moving parts according to
the manufacturer's
recommendations. Check and tighten all
bolts and chains
regularly. Inspect belts for wear and
replace them when
necessary. Keep an eye on your BOR's
pickup tines and replace any that are
bent or broken. Before each bailing
season, give your BOR a thorough
inspection. Address any issues before
you start bailing to avoid breakdowns in
the field. Outro. And there you have it,
folks, your complete guide to hay
bailing. We've covered everything from
balor types to storage techniques and
maintenance tips. Remember, good hay
bailing practices lead to better feed
for your animals and higher profits for
your farm. If you found this video
helpful, please give it a thumbs up and
share it with your farming friends. Got
any hay bailing tips or experiences to
share? Drop them in the comments below.
Thanks for watching and happy bailing.
[Music]